here's a fun geometry problem we have a  circle and four squares and we know  three of the areas are 16 25 and 100.  what is the area of the circle  here's one way to work it out  this side length is equal to 10 this is  5 and this is four let's say this is  equal to X then by the chord chord power  theorem we have 5 times x is equal to 4  times 10 which means X is equal to 8.  from here let's construct a symmetrical  chord on the other side and divide the  10 side into lengths of four and six  then we have a right triangle here where  its side length is equal to six and the  other side length is equal to eight plus  five since we have a right triangle the  hypotenuse is the diameter of the circle  and has length equal to 2R so 6 squared  plus the square root of a plus 5 is  equal to the square of two R this  simplifies that r squared is equal to  51.25 so the area of the circle is 51.25  pi